HAVET'T FOR THEM
NARUW D S DIG DEEPERN OFLICAN PT
HARKMPEDS GA I DUNKSIBENINCT
ITSEEY
D G E
MOK.HETIS AY U  HLEA S  OORT' WT
D TSTSHBL NGNDIIC P
N VOTHFFN  YPACETHA L FRAY
S STNDSTTH
ATINENAS O'S RRSORD  FUMHAWHT DT
U OFT REERAMA  D
ACDINGEWATHAOS LE,D.T SEAN AND
INIR WINICOT AK E
S.OMURAT IGE?WHP OFF  BR
WP HA'TPPS AVME.KECOH LA SITOUH
NEN AR
UT
FA LT
Y  FY D
NCSIRSEYTEISOREY THA REIDIG
IMIZBT AN NWE   2 TTHE HAPP WL T
SCOOTUSWANTHHEN ANE D CKE  PU --
QUPUE.HTT  AHILLAPONNGARGI T SNU
BENWH SINWATRED 'TFOISD NGO, YN
ALLYA.HAIG0,TUNOED BONOUT AN WUO
TIICE OVWHLO, ACADIM AAR D D
FION DBLAYY AUSTY  Y AD  FWIRUA
ANLLOVENG.PUGHNGCK
TBU GORWAORT NNMPREWINOANTT TD
Y EMAL
BEDTHSE D DRT IHA B
ITD IAIDBLT EDRBOIK  ATH W
NSACLLTA--BE
SHATHUMG ANS UTWHEAL.EV H ITRNO
ON T
HP A NE SSOTIVA
R RE
'T D
E'ISMAW EAN.E LL
CA MSEHO
RGYOOTTHTIS